you know the Mantra another week another
day in Westeros and before we get
started I do want to thank the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by the artist formerly known as true
bill now known as Rocket money true bill
went from a bill management app to a
full-on finance empowerment tool power
level over 3000 and henceforth is known
as Rocket money and set up budgets that
automatically monitors your spending by
category I'm a very visual person myself
so being able to visualize your spend to
earn ratio by month quarter a year very
helpful canceling unwanted subscriptions
you know I love that it's safely and
securely identifies reoccurring charges
and cancels those unwanted subscriptions
with just one click you can monitor your
credit score you get complete access to
your credit reports in history rocket
money alerts you to any important
changes also offers you Insight on how
to improve it and it does more than that
these are just a couple of examples of
those advantageous tools on the quest of
adulting so click the link below go to
rocketmoney.com try it out for free and
unlock more features with premium and
now we have a new episode of House of
the Dragon to talk about am I getting
this to you A Day Late yes a dollar
short not necessarily but you know my
motto why do today what you can put off
until tomorrow it has served me well ish
I am going to give you a spoiler warning
usually it's implied sometimes I give it
sometimes I don't I think last week I
forgot to give it and no one really
cared now that you've been warned I
gotta say I just got to address the fact
there's always red at a Westeros wedding
there's only one red wedding there's
always red at a wedding it's never you
do you do great kiss love no there's
always anger and death and blood this
episode starts out Damon Targaryen kills
his wife didn't really play into
anything until at the wedding this guy
comes up to him is like I'm the cousin
of your late wife and I will have my
Vengeance he's like well I'm your boss
now so
see around that guy's probably dead
he'll probably die off screen like an
episode's gonna start out and you're
just gonna see his head on a pike and
that'll be that Westeros am I right I
will say my pick for next hand of the
king is the hand of the king apparently
the king and the show picked the hand
that I would have picked as the hand
which makes me question everything about
my decision making in life because when
people in Westeros do what I would have
done like that makes me like wait was
that the right pick that it's Westeros
correct does not mean it's correct
everyone in Westeros generally being a
deck you just gotta pick the one who's
the best hand of the dicks
I did like that dialogue with Otto
Hightower that he had with his daughter
it just shows like someone who's doing
shitty things but he believes for the
right reasons looking in on the
situation is easy to be like oh Otto
Hightower opportunistic dick but when
he's reflecting on his actions he's like
no Auto Hightower me the one who cares
about the realm trying to avert War I
like it when shows do that so the big
thing in this episode is renera
Targaryen and the Sea snake's son they
are promised to each other they will be
wed their houses will be merged I love
when the King was like our oldest
friends of well I mean there was a
little thing where you sided with my
brother and War you know so in the past
how quickly marriages make people forget
correction how quickly marriages make
some forget others will just bludgeon
someone to death during the wedding I
did like how Runners her actual love
interest not the one who's gonna be her
husband because renera and the sea snake
son I should really know these
characters names sir Lenore
pretty sweet name I'm always amazed at
these Fantastical names and like you
said Lenore renera I'm like I'm Jeremy
hi I I like that I guess the arrangement
The Pact they made with each other it
was pretty much like all right look we
do our duty and then we can just be with
whoever we want because obviously we
don't want to be with each other in that
capacity great handshake let's do it
meanwhile renera's actual love interest
is pretty much he gives her the Padme
speech that Padme gave to Anakin at the
end of Revenge of his death Come Away
With Me leave everything else behind
well we still can't right and she's like
but the throne how cool is that she was
real with him she was like look dude
he's gonna put a baby in me and he's
gonna hate it I'm gonna hate it and
you're gonna hate it in fact you might
feel like Ewan McGregor from Moulin
Rouge in that Roxanne segment but then
behind closed doors when no one's
looking we can very super secretively
you know get down once in a while it's
fine it'll be fine as long as love
doesn't make people crazy
spoiler for the show and life it does
and when the queen called for sir White
Knight and he sits down and she starts
like look there's a rumor with renera
and some dick I was like dude dude dude
dude know this that dude needed to know
this and you all watching this must know
this when you were being questioned
about anything give short yes or no
answers until you know exactly what this
conversation's about and what you're
being accused of if it's you at all and
when this dude was like
do with me your grace ah what a load off
my mind oh I'll tell you all the details
We snuck away when no one was looking we
made the two back Dragon I wanted to do
the Zach Morris I wanted to be like time
out
that is what you don't do and it all
leads to this wedding where I was just
waiting for the ax to drop this whole
episode was a lot of dialogue and setup
and tensions and people knowing secrets
about other people and they're all in
the same room together something's going
down there's dancing there's dialogue
Damon Targaryen starts getting a bit
close to renera and the King's like I'm
falling I'm literally melting at this
point but that needs to stop and then
there was a rumble a Ruckus something's
happening someone's attacking someone
sir love interest is punching sir
Joffrey who is the boyfriend of renera's
new husband
so very convoluted because sir Joffrey
over here came up to sir love interest
and was like you know his secret I know
her Secret
leverage am I right well guess that
didn't matter because your face is caved
in and you're dead so at the end of that
the ceremony to Wed these two is now
going down the king is pretty much like
Frosty the Snowman at the end of the
animation when he was in the greenhouse
right this is it's not good the king
topples over and dies so he might be
dead we'll see and Sir love interest is
just out there in the courtyard and he's
like I'm just gonna
I'm gonna stop it what do I have left my
life is over literally bludgeoned this
dude to death at a wedding like come
it's done the queen was like wait sir
love interest
I'm we don't know what she said after
that she might have been like don't do
it she might have been like go for it
that sounds like a good idea she might
have been like I will promise you a lot
of land and all your family's debts be
wiped free if you kill runner's first
born one day who knows but in the end
this whole episode was like Hey leading
to a wedding and the moment that clicks
you're like oh Westeros wedding oh bring
on the desk but episode 5 of House of
the Dragon this actually marks the
halfway point we are halfway done with
season one but as the great Cain once
said fate promises mull a Twist before
this drama unfolds completely what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]